gegen ende 2017 haben sich 16
regierungschefs aus ost- mittel- und
südosteuropa mit dem chinesischen
ministerpräsidenten getroffen das war
das sechste mal und es ging um eine
vertiefung der wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen und chinesische
investitionen
heute in vechta kompakt chinas neue
seidenstraße ambition und skepsis
[Musik]
die alte seidenstraße war über
jahrhunderte hinweg der wichtigste
handelsweg zwischen china und europa
lange zeit in vergessenheit geraten ist
sie seit 2013 wieder in aller munde
der chinesische präsident hu jintao
diese neuen seidenstraße die sogenannte
bild und welt initiativ ganz aktiv
vorantreiben sie soll in arabische
afrikanische asiatische länder führen
aber auch nach europa die vorstellungen
die dimensionen sind gigantisch mehr als
60 länder sollen erfasst werden
über 60 prozent der weltbevölkerung lebt
in diesem raum eine billion dollar soll
investiert werden die infrastruktur 30
prozent der weltwirtschaftsleistung
erfolgt ihren die transportzeiten sollen
radikal verkürzt werden schon heute
benötigt entzug von der ostküste chinas
bis nach london 18 tage das sind 12.000
kilometer ein schiff würde 30 bis 60
tage benötigen die neue seidenstraße ist
ein netzwerk aus handels- und
transportrouten das von china in die
regionen führt alte linien sollen
ausgebaut werden neu dazu gebaut werden
um eine bessere vernetzung zu
ermöglichen besprechen von sechs land
korridoren und einem sieg im norden für
dein land korridor über die mongolei
nach russland es besteht bereits südlich
davon die neue euro asiatische land
brücke die endpunkte hat in london und
in madrid wir haben einen weg nach
pakistan ein alter verbündeter der
massiv ausgebaut werden soll mit
autobahnen
und gaspipelines und in der hafenstadt
quader im süden enden soll
wir haben eine route in den süden nach
indochina zu den südostasiatischen
staaten
wir haben eine querverbindung über mia
und indien nach bangladesch und wir
haben eine route in den
zentralasiatischen raum der über den
iran und der türkei
die mittelmeer regierung im osten
erschließen soll
der weg führt von der chinesischen
ostküste über den golf von bengalen an
die ostafrikanischen küste geht hinauf
in das rote meer suezkanal und in das
mittelmeer
die neue seidenstraße ist zwar primär
ein wirtschaftliches projekt sie hat
aber enorme geopolitische und
sicherheitspolitische auswirkungen
pekings ambitionen werden in diesem
zusammenhang von vielen sehr skeptisch
gesehen
sie meinen dass peking dieses projekt
dazu benutzt um seine eigene position
als wild macht auszubauen und zu
festigen
russland sieht grün ist die zunehmende
abhängigkeit der zentralasiatischen
staaten von china
das ist der raum der ehemaligen
sowjetunion moskau das sagen hatte
indien misstraut wieder dem engagement
weil es hier eine stärkung des erz
rivalen pakistan in der region sieht
durch china vor allem in kaschmir
konflikt und die usa achten sehr darauf
was diese neue ambition hier für die
sicherheit der eigenen verbündeten in
der region bedeuten kann auch in europa
insbesondere in der eu gibt es kritische
stimmen
man sieht zwar das unglaubliche
wirtschaftliche potenzial aber viele
verweisen darauf dass hier china
vielleicht kritische infrastruktur
aufkaufen könnte bahnlinien oder
kommunikationsverbindungen dass staaten
in finanzielle abhängigkeit geraten
könnte durch sehr hohe kredite dass auch
das zusammenwachsende eu gefährdet wird
weil hier alternativen geboten werden
die nicht den strengen eu standards um
vorgaben unterliegen und insbesondere
fürchtet man dass hier die mühsamen
transformationsprozesse auf dem balkan
gefährdet werden weil hier
nationalistische kräfte wieder auftrieb
erhalten könnten
welche sicherheitspolitischen
auswirkungen sind daher denkbar
grundsätzlich ist festzuhalten dass eine
verstärkte zusammenarbeit und vernetzung
konflikten vorbeugt in dem zusammenhang
gibt es aber natürlich schon kritische
punkte das ist wer hat zugriff auf öl
auf gas und auf andere wertvolle
ressourcen
wer kontrolliert die strategischen
kommunikationslinien wer kann sie
unterbrechen und auch zu erwähnen
finanzielle abhängigkeiten einzelner
staaten die natürlich sich sehr negativ
auswirken könnten vielleicht am rande
nicht zu vergessen china brachte jetzt
sehr viele eigene arbeitskräfte ins
ausland zu schicken dass wir natürlich
auch ein konfliktpotenzial
die bild den roten nicht
tief ist zweifelsohne das größte
wirtschafts und geopolitische projekt
der jetztzeit kann sie erfolgreich sein
das hängt vor allem davon ab wie
kooperationsbereit die über 60 staaten
sind ist hängt von der inneren
stabilität chinas ab und es hängt auch
von zusätzlichen faktoren wie bewaffnete
konflikte oder auch naturkatastrophen ab
als europäischer perspektive betrachtet
europa ist massiv in diesem projekt
erfasst und europa insbesondere die eu
wäre sehr gut beraten hier eine position
zu haben geschlossen aufzutreten um ein
entsprechendes gewicht und
durchsetzungsvermögen gegenüber peking
zu haben